welcome to the heavy spoilers show i'm
your host paul
and after a 10 week long journey we're
now at the finale of lovecraft country
throughout this video we're going to be
going over the entire episode
and breaking down all of the easter eggs
and things that you might have missed
there will be heavy spoilers here so if
you haven't had a chance to check it out
yet then i highly recommend that you
check out now
please subscribe to the channel as you
still have a lot of lovecraft stuff to
talk about after this video
and you definitely don't want to miss it
without the way thank you for clicking
this
now let's get into the breakdown okay so
episode 10 is titled full circle
and it's probably the most
straightforward name so far
everything comes full circle but that
doesn't mean
it's pointless get it because because
circles don't have points now never mind
there's a circle spell used at one point
which reunites all of the free mints
around their worst ancestor titus
and throughout the entry circles pop up
at several key points
the episode brings everything to a close
and fulfills the prophecy that was laid
out with the book lovecraft country
i wish i just used that as a plot
summary because they pretty much spoiled
the entire season
in episode 8. however there are a lot of
things up in the air
and showrunner misha green has stated
that she has ideas for a second entry
but sadly nothing has been confirmed yet
now the book ends with the group going
head to head with captain lancaster
and caleb who christina is based upon
he gets stripped of his powers and
atticus montrose horatio who is george's
son
and basically all of the characters end
up getting a happy ending
with the core group heading off on a
road trip across america
in the hopes that things will change
it's more of a hopeful and upbeat way to
close things
with montrose and tick repairing their
father and son relationship
and forming a bond where they move in a
new direction together
as they build more pages in the travel
guide however the season goes in a
completely different direction
but we do get hints of this and actually
open with a shot of the travel guide
hinting at the way things ended in the
source material now as we know
the show is dealing heavily with the
multiverse so one can view the book as
an alternate dimension
and this was even hinted at with the
original protagonist being called
atticus turner
whereas in the series he's called
atticus freeman the episode opens with
the group returning from the observatory
with diana
and atticus starts the spell to free her
from the curse which is when the book of
names flips open
and stops on the page of his birthmark
this causes tick and letty to faint
and they wake up in the ancestral plane
which is a similar sort of aesthetic to
what we saw in black panther
the burning lodge is an important place
for the freemans as
it's well the moment they became free
and it's also where the lineage of titus
breithwight would be carried on
and thus it's a pivotal scene which
would lead to the events that we see
play
out in the show now atticus meets hannah
whereas letty who's bearing his child
meets hattie from last week we
discovered that in order to hide them
hannah created a spell which is the
birthmark that tick and his family will
share
this in some ways backfired though and
actually also created this ancestral
plane for all of them
in which they could find sanctuary
spiritually hannah states that
every night she would end up in the
ancestral plain and that she initially
believed that this was hell
she soon learned to wield it though and
it became somewhat of a paradise
now as we know all her descendants come
here and i believe that this symbolizes
generational pain
it's something that we've talked about
throughout the season and though
i can't fully grasp it myself a lot of
people of color who've been in touch
with the show have stated that they feel
like they're born into a world where
they have the past and the pain caused
by it
constantly looming over them this is
very much the case here
and hannah tried to rid herself of this
so she opened the book of names to seal
it
at some point though hannah realized
that the fire was a representation of
the fire within her
and there were also hints of this in
last week's episode when we heard sonia
sanchez's poem
catch the fire which too is about
fueling rage and pain in order to keep
you going
hannah has harnessed the fire and
created a binding spell
and both take and let you learn that
they must sacrifice him in order to
fully deliver it
and there are some excellent scenes here
and atticus reunites with his mother and
she tells him that he has the best parts
of both george and montrose
we don't learn who the true father is
just yet but the fact that they leave it
ambiguous
makes me think that it is likely george
there's very much this idea of
sacrificing oneself in order to make
sure that the future can be better
and it's something that we as humans
often have to deal with
now though we aren't out here performing
incantations like the people in the show
i love that this series has been laced
with the idea that the older generation
almost have some sort of duty to try and
make things better for the younger ones
and it's something we should all strive
for at some point they stand around
diana and heal her
though she loses her arm in the process
which as we guessed
leads to her being the woman in the
future with the robotic limb
i also love that diana has solar system
pajamas
as her mother of course is heavily
interested in astronomy
now they debate the plan back and forth
as it involves tick having to put
himself in the firing line
they actually state they wish to rob
christina of her magic
which i appreciate as it's what they do
in the source material
tick and letty head to titus's vault and
along the way he puts his hand
over a panel which is holding his shog
off as many of you pointed out this
suggoth is actually black
and i love how it shows that he too can
wield the power that was once
exclusively only available to white
people
in the basement they summon titus using
the resurrection spell
and hannah arrives too titus sees
himself
as an awfully kind man and states that
he gave hannah
more than any other black person had i
think this is a reference to the section
in the book
in which kayla pays montrose money in
retribution for how his family treated
theirs
caleb views this as doing montrose a
favor when in reality
montrose and his family were owed a lot
more than money
this is something that's often brought
up in the case of reparations
and it's estimated that due to the
system african americans
lost out on 1.4 trillion dollars thus
we aren't really doing them a favor by
just paying them back
and it's what they should have had in
the first place now i could just be
reading into that but you know you know
i love the source material and
any connection to that i can make with
the show i always try and do it
now titus escapes and goes to christina
which causes her to crash the car
however due to her invulnerability spell
she's okay
we see that she never gave one to ruby
and get further hints towards their
relationship
dynamic titus tries to tell her what
tick and car are up to
but he summoned back and tick cuts the
organ out of him that's needed for the
ceremony
we actually saw something similar to
this being performed on samuel in
episode 2
and it's a nice little call back to the
performance of that knight
our titus gets snapped and along with
the rest of the descendants
they fade to ash i think this is
actually a nod to the bible
namely the verse ashes to ashes dust to
dust which is often used as a symbolism
of death
now this resurrection spell is important
as i actually think that it's a way in
which atticus can be brought back
from what we see of titus he is able to
escape and move around
and it is possible that a kiss could
return through this method
however we'll get more into that later
on in the video and hippolyta goes and
visits diana in bed
and the pair discuss how the former had
to leave in order to become arithia blue
though hippolyta got to free herself
from her box diana
was very much left abandoned and again
we get this idea of the older generation
having to give up something so that the
younger generation can thrive
ideally hippolyta should have remained
behind and given up her dreams so that
diana could be safe
however they don't really confirm that
and i do like the way that the show
wrestles over this motif
as it often does paint out elders as
being there to care for others
and not themselves now hippolyta goes to
tick montrose and letty
and decides to help in their plan which
is when christina arrives
she tries to get the buck in order to
find a way to cast her spell without
sacrificing tick
but tick denies her this and christina
storms out
absolutely furious removing letty's mark
of cane in the process
the group head back to the winthrop
house and across the street we see that
a black couple
have moved in there this shows that
though letty's move may have seemed
pretty insignificant at first
she truly was a pioneer that inspired
others to do the same
thing we also see the blood mark on the
door which is used as protection
though i don't know if it's just me but
it seems to be fading slightly
hinting that danger could be coming for
them soon
tick calls gr and we see across town a
man is trying to chat her up
by asking where she's from the first
place he says is japan
and clearly this is commenting on how a
lot of western people
pretty much always assume that asian
people are either chinese or japanese
even though there's a diverse range of
eastern countries and areas
tick goes and meets here and we learn
that her mother died
we did guess that she was going to be
the final soul that was needed to lift
the curse
but as we see the kumio later in the
episode it becomes clear that she died
recently
and didn't give herself up in order to
free her daughter
gr says that she's destined to enter the
darkness but tick tells her they can be
heroes or monsters
this is mirrored nicely by ruby meeting
with letty at their mother's grave
ruby 2 has a choice and she goes on
quite an interesting arc for the finale
letty admits that she didn't go to their
mother's funeral because she was in jail
at the time
and regrets the way their family were
she informs ruby that she needs her in
order to get a part of christina to use
in the spell
and ruby realizes that she's being used
and tells her
that letty only really wants to be her
sister when she wants something
if you cast your mind back to episode 1
you may recall that she gave her a
similar speech when like he arrived
looking for somewhere to stay
but this time instead of agreeing to it
ruby initially denies her
however letty tells her more how we
cutted diana who's having to learn how
to draw right-handed
we can see on the newspaper that she's
scribbling on that the headline reads
all white all-male jewry acquits emmett
till's murderers
this actually happened in real life and
the people behind the crime
admitted to killing emmett after the
fact but they
weren't ever prosecuted because of the
double jeopardy laws
it's a true case of injustice and shows
just how rigged that the system really
is
under her door hippolyta slides a comic
which documents her travels across the
universe diana doesn't believe that
she'll be able to ever draw again like
that
and hippolyta takes her to a room which
is where she gives her a robotic arm
hippolyta has decided to focus on her
children now
rather than herself and again it's this
notion of sacrifice
ruby goes to christina where the latter
discusses how the spell will work
and the two kiss as their true selves
for the first time
ruby's journey has very much been about
self-acceptance
i think this moment holds a lot of
weight to it as
it is her truly deciding what kind of
person she wants to be
now she is accepting that she does love
christina
however she also loves her family and
with this spell laid out like that
she knows what she must do in order to
help her sister
jump to tick getting baptized valetti
who as we know has started to become
more and more religious she's found god
inside herself
and the two share a really tender moment
with one another that culminates in a
montage
in which nina simone i am blessed plays
tick truly is
and for once he sees his family his
community
organized in together unified by one
common goal
they scramble to woody and ruby
apparently arrives to give letty a piece
of christina
we later learn that this is actually
christina and that she caught ruby
trying to steal from her
she then killed her and took her
appearance and it's a big twist that
shows
though christina did love her she too
was willing to do
whatever it took in order to achieve her
goals throughout our breakdowns we've
discussed how ruby often viewed herself
as somewhat of a partner to christina
when that was never really the case and
in fact it was very much a master
servant relationship in which christina
completely controlled her
it's sad that in the end this came to
fruition
and i wasn't expecting it at all it's
the first time
we really see christina as the big bad i
think it works
really really well now on the road she
says that she felt this sense of family
and that it was nice sitting listening
to shaboom life could be a dream about
the coasters
i love this scene and it felt like the
much needed calm before the storm
in which all of our characters were
happy and together
upon arriving at autumn they enter the
woods and we hear the ominous soundtrack
of the village creep in
as tick eats the piece of titus that
they took from him earlier in the
episode
they form a salt circle however we pull
out to see what looks like a much bigger
one
surrounding the lodge in the ruins the
villagers arrive
and they also surround the group on the
outskirts overpowering them with these
christina throws letty off the tower
which kills her again
though she does return but i'm sure
she's sick of being killed at this point
in the woods diana is attacked by a
shoghorth however
she's saved by ticks which we learn he
taught her to use
christina arrives to carry out the
ceremony dressed in what looks like
a wedding dress and i think this has
been chosen because she's tying both
tick's life
and his family to hers there's very much
this symbology that black bodies have
been used in order to empower white
people
and i love the symmetry of letty lying
on the ground montrose being knocked out
and take two being tied in a submissive
position to showcase this motif
christina carries his ceremony out and
is showered with blood
further showcasing how the blood of
black people has been used to
in the lives of white people this is
also what gr
saw and i think the ending should be
taken that because
take went to her for help they were able
to piece together from her prophecy
some parts of what would happen and
prepare for it in advance
the showrunner did go into this in more
depth in their interview with collider
and stated that the finale very much
represents the darkness that was
prophesied for gr
and how she becomes instrumental in
changing things
what i kind of took this as is pocs
uniting against the common cause of
inequality to help one another
and we watch as letty steps forward and
stabs christina
whilst jr halter in place with the kumio
tentacles
this is the binding spell and itali's
not only taking christina together
but also all white people who possess
magic on the planet
this strips them of their abilities and
it very much levels the playing field
misha green stated that atticus was very
much someone who was fighting his
destiny
which was to die but in the end he
accepted it in order to upset the power
balance
and held things even out leading to
equality for all those who had been
victim to the magic wielding white
people
over the last few centuries tick dies as
his father battles with realizing the
fate he's tried to protect him from has
come true
and hippolyta presents him with the
letter that tick wrote for him
take really gave his life to protect and
free everyone
and this has allowed for everyone to be
united there's a lot of crucifixion
symbolism laced within tick's death
and i definitely think it stands in
place to show that he gave up his life
in order to help other people he hopes
that montrose finds the second chance at
being a father
that he always wanted in his grandson
george and asks him
not to waste the opportunity the season
ends with christina under the rubble
and diana arrives to strangle her with
her new robotic arm
not leaving anything to chance she says
that she still hasn't learned
because christina calls out for help
from black people
even though she tried to ruin their
lives and was happy to step on them in
order to achieve her goals
now ends the season on the future
generation taking control into their own
hands
and it does hint to what i think will
happen in the series
now though it is possible to bring tick
back through the use of the resurrection
spell
i actually think they're gonna do
something different in her interview
with collider
green said that she wanted to use the
book story to platform off into
discovering other races
and people such as asians mexican
americans and so on
could be appearing in the future though
she remained tight-lipped over what
would be happening
if there is a second season i actually
think that we've already had hints to it
already
now when tick traveled to the future we
learned that there had been several
riots
and i believe that the next season could
take place close to modern day
and show things from the perspective of
his son george we know that diana is a
huge part of this feature
and thus it makes sense as to why the
season ends on her
now white people are obviously gonna be
annoyed that they've lost their power
all of a sudden
i think it's very much gonna showcase
how they're trying to take back control
by oppressing others diana and george
will have to fight back against this
and this will lead to the civil unrest
that atticus saw in the future
diana will sort of be george's auntie i
think
i'm not sure of the whole family tree
thing with the way things are but
i can see her sort of being a mentor and
george may retrace his father's
footsteps in order to create the book
before the show goes off into a new
direction i'd love to see the time
travel scene from the future's
perspective
with ticks showing up to get the book
before disappearing into the past
but hey that's just wishful thinking for
now anyway
that's the ending but let me know your
thoughts and theories below
okay and that concludes the season and
what a season it's been
i think this show has been such an
eye-opener in terms of bringing things
to the forefront
that aren't ever really discussed in tv
shows or the media
whether it's the korean war or the tulsa
massacre
this has put things out in the open that
deserve attention
even though unfortunately they don't
really get it for example when
researching the tulsa massacre
it brought up false numbers such as 36
as the official amount of deaths
when the real total is more than 10
times that
it shows things need to change and that
there's a lot of ways we can do this
such as acknowledging history and
holding ourselves to account
to make sure it doesn't happen again now
on top of being educational
lovecraft country is also an incredible
fantasy journey
that's touched upon several genres and
honestly
made some of the best entries in them
i've seen for a long time
whether it was the horror elements the
riffs on indiana jones
sci-fi or time travel it expertly pulled
these off
and it's a credit to the creative team
and cast that the show managed to
constantly change the way it worked
whilst also keeping things consistent i
absolutely loved it
and also thank you everyone each week
for dropping your comments and feedback
on the videos
which has helped me to improve my
perspectives understand the context
better
and though i still feel like i'll never
fully grasp certain things
i appreciate people explaining them
obviously i'd love to hear your thoughts
on the episode
and season and again thank you for
contributing so much
you're the best and if you missed any of
our videos then make sure you check them
out after this
if you want to support the channel and
get to see content early then please
consider clicking the join button below
you can also come chat us on a discord
server linked in the description
or have you spoilers on twitter thanks
for making it until the end of the video
you've been the best i've been paul and
hopefully i'll see you next time
take care peace
you